il ya deux ans quand j'ai commencé à
monter sur scène ici au pas la marque
qui a fait à paris
voici un extrait de ma toute première
scène filmée par cyprien me disais je me
suis rendu compte que c'était moins
facile de parler devant des vrais gens
que devant une caméra
oui j'avais envie de ce challenge alors
je me suis entraîné sept jours sur sept
pendant deux ans et que ça te connais je
sais pas au succès et puis deux ans plus
tard j'ai la chance de pouvoir jouer
dans des zénith complet
[Applaudissements]
non pas comme ça et moi je suis un mec
hyper connus hyper célèbre chez les gens
qui sont censés 20 cette tournée des
zénith c'est l'une des plus belles
expériences de ma vie alors j'ai voulu
en partager un petit bout avec vous
histoire de vous montrer un peu ce que
je fais depuis deux ans quand j'ai passé
youtube
[Musique]
j'ai joué partout il ya plein de dates
sont super bien passé et d'autres mondes
lui c'est le mec qui assure la première
partie de mon spectacle c'est mon pote
naumann oui j'avais une chance sur un
milliard de tomber sur un mec ayant un
prénom qui ressemble à 99% on vient
finalement ce plutôt à ça rigolo battus
à notre grande moins un an ça va allez
merci aux mains de nos mal aussi
voilà cénomane pas normal to be er ok
y'a pas d'heure j'ai une petite surprise
pour vous c'est ma première partie il
faut savoir google me reconnais pas suis
tapé naumann sur google en général il va
te dire vouliez-vous dire norman fait
des vidéos pas chez lui c'est gérard mon
batteur oui j'ai un batteur son truc à
lui c'est qu'il fait des débats surtout
pas vraiment surtout et et de manière
permanente
quand tu vois le prix du cacao en arabie
saoudite
moi je suis désolé quoi ça me donne plus
envie de manger du chocolat
tu imagines si tu as ramène ça la vision
humaine
[Musique]
on s'en fout si tu les chars
tu es vraiment intéressant lui ces
petites touches il est fait de muscles
de muscles et de muscles qui touche
il s'occupe de plein de trucs notamment
avertir les gens ne pas filmer durant le
spectacle
d'ailleurs pour attirer leur attention
discrètement il utilise un petit laser
en gros il l'a zerrifi les gens quoi
bien sûr mon spectacle serait rien sans
les 30 courageux technicien qui installe
et des install ma scène chaque jour non
je peux la grosse tête comme je suis un
exemple que tous les jours j'avais un
bonjour à mes potos technicien sa venue
non mais j'y vais j'y mets johan ces
balades non je travaille pas ici je
travaille pas ici avec qui on travaille
ensemble pour que chaque soir le
spectacle soit parfait gb dijonnais
[Musique]
n'ont franchement j'ai bossé avec des
gens super pro parfois même un peu trop
gros j'ai pas le bas jamais dans ma loge
mais si vous n'êtes pas je vous fais pas
c'est moi qui fais le spectacle
l'artiste de hip hop vous rentrez pas
ici sur le bouton select
je rêvais celui sans qui mon spectacle
n'aurait jamais existé
c'est bien sûr mon metteur en scène
qaîda rhône c'est un peu mon mentor il
connaît plein de trucs qui parle le
plein de trucs il parle aussi beaucoup
d'algérie 1 en fait
il parle tout le temps de l'algérie
quelqu'un a vu mon drapeau algérien
[Musique]
la saison du spectacle des plus sincères
qui doit être c'est que petit pierre et
algériennes quand tu sais c'est
l'instinct parfois après spectacle on
sort un peu en boîte pour détendre mais
c'est vrai qu'un mardi soir en boîte
dans les vosges à saint dié
l'ambiance est pas toujours au top
[Musique]
dans mon spectacle je parle de plein de
trucs un peu comme dans mes vidéos je
parle de sujets qui nous concernent tous
je parle un petit peu de ma vie aussi
notamment de mon métier un petit peu
bizarre ce qu'on appelle un youtube
hoerdtois abordé jeudi ce mot je
chantais petit guillemets comme ça c'est
un métier un peu spécial il ya plein de
métiers au tout pas employer les
guillemets tu vas faire là je présente
c'est moi votre chirurgien
ouais je m'occupais personnellement de
votre cref du coeur dont classe tout se
passe bien la fin vous devriez être
vivant à tu peux pas faire ça quoi qu'il
en soit cette tournée je la kiffe vous
avez déjà été 150 mille spectateurs à
venir me voir si j'essaie vraiment
important le nombre de spectateurs est
ce que l'important c'est pas le plaisir
de l'art girard on s'en fout pas tant
merci mon spectacle en tout cas il est
fait pour tous
du coup il y avait vraiment de tout des
filles mignonnes des couples mignon des
tatoués des bavarde des bien coiffé
décoiffé xulu des 100 cheveux des barons
des licornes des mamies des recoupent
mignon des roms amis etc
je suis bien content parce que même mon
père est venu voir mon spectacle enfin
je veux dire il était présent à mon
spectacle quoi finalement la seule
personne qui a raté mon passage sur
scène où je parle de mon père abbas et
mon père je parle de toi passage du
spectacle je parle de toi voilà vous en
savez un peu plus sur moi et mon métier
en dehors de youtube qui a remercié
l'équipe vidéo qui nous a suivis pendant
ces longs mois de tournée à travers la
france la suisse la belgique ainsi que
la marque fanta qui nous a donné les
moyens de réaliser cette vidéo en
coulisse râler parce que sans eux dans
cette vidéo elle ressemblait à ça avant
sachez que j'oublie pas lui vient je
sais grâce à qui j'en suis là et
j'oublie pas chaque soir de vous
remercier sur scène j'aimerais
difficile un bruissement pour les
million d'inconnues d'abonnés
internautes ils vont confirme depuis
quatre jours au lit quand une vidéo
je viens ce soir
je blesse
voilà tournée terminée mais je continue
mon spectacle ici à paris pour palace
mais rue du faubourg montmartre dans le
9e à partir du 15 octobre 2015
alors venez savamment est très cool j'ai
hâte de vous voir à traiter très vite
ciao à l'époque il n'y avait pas à
l'époque
vous ne lisez pas on lit causé sur lycos
on se donnait encore sur msn pour
s'envoyer with
[Musique]